heilige zitel sie alles ganz schön
friedlich und den das knar unterem
wnachtsbaum wie sportlich ne über das
reden wir
[Musik]
h wir nach das fast V der lieb stad vor
der D wie man die heikel gradwander kan
schaffen zwischen verweigerig und
verklärri über das reden wir h aber z er
mal gotum
derwtigshaltigge wie hoch ist
derwtigsdruck bei dir ziemlich würde ich
sagen also B ja wir nach irgendwie so
große erw das F große Primborium drum
jetzt nicht so
wichtigart wie immer gich so oder so
Ritual sondern
wichtig und ja vi singen trinken so mich
schö ich freue mich immer
aufteres manageminar Versche immer oder
erw
dass mir nicht so stark religiös
sozialisiert sind und die chrlich
Religion SPI ke Rolle daheimen oder und
ich GLB Gewicht von dem F die hö
erwfehler mit dem oder ist die Geburt
vom Erlöser und so weiter und das ist im
Hintergrund und so und das ist nicht ich
GL
Sarkasmus aber viel mit dem du aber sag
wenn du ein religiös Rah h h du Ganzes
ritualo funktioniert und will Familie du
mit wo du im grundicht nicht so viel mit
und plötzlich sit den am Tisch mit die
nicht so gut ver und dann
Ritual gen ungefähr den lauft
alles extrem ja du weß was ich Ritual
halte ich sind sozial akzeptier die
kollektive Zwangsneurose ich glaube also
ich bra das korsig also was ist jetzt
das Ritual W immer Mö plötzlich für
stimmt da muss sich de füen und so das
ist ich finde ich freue mich zum neues
mal
daend vor Spazier oder so verschiedene
Sache do schön also es muss
nicht so gut D Ritual dazu führt dass
man weiß es funktioniert und wenn wieder
von ne was machen wir
jetzt im Winter
and komiert
nicht gro Verwandschaft
oder okay ja
nur
und Berge und das finde wichtig Abstand
zu dem ganz und vorher vor der nicht z
Sport ma und
und schön
ja so ich
finde ganz wichtig
wie damit zum knat und damit zpr
ir
diskutiert
wasch aber zur ich meine
der Familie ist eigentlich für das heßt
wenn du natürlich h wo z.bin stehend ist
dann ist für die Person schwerchluss
finden und umgekehrt wenn du jetzt als
Sohn se Liebe zu denen Eltern ke gar
nichtach bin ich den gespannt ob so
entspannt ist B dieim klar ich meine der
warruck aber der kom nicht irgendwo das
ist natürlich aus der Religion die ganze
geschich V der Heilige Familie und Maria
Josef und und so weer das wird irgendwie
idealisiert plus der ganz Kapitalismus
natürlich Schlachtfeld od das kan
unglaublich achlacht das ich fin das
muss alles wie wssen und denn das
abekocht hinter frag und sag warum ist
es Familie F V der lie warum soll das
andere gute Freund und soer das glaub
ich alles gar nicht aber wenn halt so
Familientraditionen im Spiel sind dann
ist also ich w nicht dass du bei
mir kaputt lache ich müsste mich mega
sch vor
dir die Sachen machen du findest ja
alles lerlich natürlich Singen am wir
machen
Musik wer immer noch wie früh ich fin
das alles schön stell und soer ich
aber finden ich kannz bind ich find das
die Ritual die Ver mit die Ver im
letztlich ist Form V Umgang mit
derlichkeit das immer
wiederehrende bewusst macht es ist alles
ein er under aber
irgendwn got wi
ja ich find es mit Unsicherheit mit
Angst wo man den irgendwie sich bis fest
muss h was größer ist al ein selber wenn
jetzt Ritual redet glaube ich ja du
spielst dich
Therapeut Ritual bra zitual be daser
also das ist der Zustand wo man
Kontrollen abgt verlt oder die
Übergangsritual das ist alles nicht so
Angst
macht aber ich glaub es
mitinh sch
Erin
W sag PAP wieso
hab ne
[Gelächter]
irgendwas
ma gut die Diskussion ab und 20 J
fr
ja mit Sprengkraft belad familed doch
malüber warum Familien so
kompliziiert ja ich glaub da gibt's
mehrere gründ also ein ist so die
falsche nö wo man glaubt zu Verwandte zu
Brüder Mutter Vater Ritual nein also gut
Fal ja ich glaub die H alle also ich
glaub mir inemmer irgendwie verwandt ist
und das blut ist dicker das Wasser und Z
meint man mir Verst sehr gut und mit
Teil das Weltbild und haltig und WT und
das ist nicht immer so das muss
überhaupt nicht so sie sehr sehr
Menach undag verwandt miteinand aber das
macht ich GLB das ist wirklich und dar
immer wieder ist geschockt dass der eig
Vater oder der Brüder oder was immer so
anders ist und nicht sind ganz
unterschiedlich men GL das ist das muss
man wie W sehr
klarul der
W oder Familie
vorsichtig und das Widerspruch will
natürlich wä es gut man könte die
vorsichtig sie es ist extrem
identitätsstiften ist wahnsinnig prägend
Familie mir geboren werdet und
aufwachset und gich kann man sich halt
nicht wäh sonder muss arrangieren also
die Idee von der Wahlverwandtschaft die
geht nur GTE das ist ein Wunschkonzert
geht's nicht in der Realität ja aber es
ist natürlich so wenn ich jetzt mit dem
nicht biologische Vater aufgewachsen W
wä das genauso n die Big also es ist
sehr stark konstruiert ist Geschichte
sind derlnis derinner wo man Teil das
ist nicht Blut od geh wo man teilt oder
z sehr sehr groß Teil das ist ja wichtig
zuen oder Familie genau Familie kann
soziologisch definieren ja genau würde
ein aber gerade will quasi die lange
Geschichte ist und dich so extrem prägt
dich zum macht W ich jetzt kenne ist m
so D wenn Familie zurück D
diecht das istem für die schrecklich die
neu zu hinzugekommenen oder also wenn
jetzt quasi die Frau mit kommt und die
benimmt sich weder wieine
mit dem Brüder in die rol und sie kennt
dich nicht so wer ist das ja das ist
immer total also ich fin das
wahnsinnigtierend wenn Partner
Kind ein was
Roll PLZ andere andere Charakter
zeigticht aber bei dir selber beobacht
das nicht ich Ken das von mir das ist
extrem irritierend GLB das starke Ding W
wieder die Muster die rollebilder
zurück dugö wieder nicht stimmt oder D
ir reduziert
W 20 J soppt oder der Konstellation das
ist extrem prägend ja der Peter Weiß so
schön gesagt Familie Elter Vater Mutter
das sind portalfiguren unseres Lebens
die wir quasi
Portal und die Ken wir nicht vom Sockel
stoßen du kanst dich zwar los sagen von
Elter also du kan Kontakt abbrechen z.B
aber du WST die Figur als die prägen die
Geschicht nicht los es geht auch
Expartner oder exfreundinne z. aber es
git natlich ke exmutter oder exvater das
gibt's nicht und es gibt ke
exkinder die einzige bezieh W
unbaris ja aber ich finde das
istchlossen logische dass ich ter ich
die er J GT und noch irg Grund TR ich
binen und soer
daster mehr für mich andere msche sehr
viel Stärke Prät we ich fin das ist re
wenn du sagst das W sprach richtig aber
das muss nicht drüber sag wie wichtig
sie sind für dich ST Recht und trotzdem
würde ich sagen eig Herkunft arbeitet
man sich ab und das natürlich auch gich
den nicht nur mit der Geschicht sondern
auch mit der gen und ich glaub das ist
so eine große Beleidigung für moderne
individuelle Mensche dass mir glaub wir
Kön Grund auf neu erfinden K selber
definieren aber vieles ist tatsächlich
auch ich Schw vem den wenn ich Kind sage
t ich oft wie me Vater oder meine Mutter
K das ist wirk Klassiker und Sel
zu
ja ja und merst wie t das ist oder mit D
das inegangen ist die Sache wo s gesagt
eine von der Schwierigkeit und ich
glaube wo mit Familie sind die große
Schuldgefühl es ist natürlich auch so
ein Ort wo man erwartet gesellschaftlich
erwartet dass Familiie zinander l also
das Blut ist dickeras Wasser es ist
erwartet dass erwachsen Kind ihr Elteren
irgendwie s sie regelmäßig und gerade
der wachte also ich glaube wenn man als
älter Teil z.B verwitwet ist und den
alle zurück BBT und die eig K nicht dann
geht's einersit t Schmerz dass man alle
BBT so sch aber vielleicht sogar dazu no
der Blick von der Nachbarin ah ja sie
sind es ist schon fo sehr stark mit der
Schuldgefühl belastet ist ja ein die
familiär aber andere Leute das nicht ke
Familie h der Z oder wo ich GLB das
unglaublich schlimme d
drüber R was schlimm istchn und so
weiter Problem aber wo das nicht hat hat
ganz andere Problem musag und ich würde
immer sagen es ist keine gute Idee mit
Schuldgefühl ander zu bewegen den gich
die Familie bezieh auf rechts erhalten
will Schuld das he zwar starke Form
Verbindig aber nicht der Grund warum W
dass man der Kontakt
son lie und ger und dankbar sind und
soer K ja du schön Buch über das Thema
warum Elter nicht sch und ich fin ein
super Argument drin aber ich würich sag
Punkt ist doch so klar hab ich jetzt
nicht könen wäh dass ich auf Welt kommen
und so weiter und ich bin abhängig und
meine Elter das Wunsch ihnen oder h und
sie Schu mir mal oder das mir gut gehönt
dass sie mich nicht
einfach aber mit der Z komus der
Abhängigkeit wie augenhö stand und dann
kanst du wertschätzen was S dir g du kan
das stüre du kannst dankbar und dann
find die Schul wenn man gute bezieh oder
aber das ist genau thesee ist den
sozusagen n Schuld wo um Transaktion
geht also du musst zurück was du über h
sondern ist Schuldigkeit wo auf Relation
beruht auf bezieh und das ist ganz dem
sagen wir normal nicht schuld das sind
einfach GÜ W werden innere bezieho
bezieh immer wieder stiftet in dem dass
du Freundschaft genau bin
Parallelität ist schwierig aber das ist
ganz ander
themaade jetzt drüber Familien ist
ambivalent großes Geschenk aber B
schwierig und an wach das ganze eskali
jetzt reden drüber wie Ken wir der
familenarch verhinderen ja also ich
glaube muss meset mit der richtigge Hal
das ganze in das find ich wichtig also
ich
wür
ich w sag nicht irgendwie dem über die
große politische Frage sondern es geht
drum um sch ich selber ma
gerne oder singe oder Pack nicht
ritualisiert B aber
Aktion erinner gestiftet find schönpr
aber
machen SP Z SP noch SP
okay we doch doch wir
machenis zu später Stunde nach paarer
Schnaps und dann ist es sehr lustig aber
ich bin h mit dem dass man nicht
politische Gespräch sucht ich finde es
hilft
miragkel frit sitzt und werich blöde
sexistis Spruch verzäht das
so sportlich ne trainingslabor für
geistige
Offenheit
stimm es ist sch Stück wie ist meistens
UMG jetzt mit Freunden und Freundinen wo
ungefähr gich denk wo die giche
politischen aicht und gerade der Familie
h zwar die familieschicht verbindet aber
viicht denk man total anders und das
finde ich auch riesige Chance ist e Form
von mentalem Stretching duchen Wiech
oder Familie F will mit anderen
Positionen konfrontiert wir aber das
nicht sehr anstrengend und eskaliw
Alkohol und soiter also wenn du also was
heißt das klar h du z und das aushalten
aber wenn noch GPR g gibt die mechanisme
V verhertig und zurück Backfire Effekt
und all das und D noch ein H
was nicht W oder ja aber ich glaub es
macht doch ob du du musst die anderen
irendwie belehren oder ob du undst wie
interessant was es da noch für geht auf
der Welt das
and andere haltig es gibt ein schönen
Text Chester britische Schriftsteller wo
drüber schriebt dass es immer so dieide
Geister dass M sousag best drin Dorf
Verl aus der Familie die will die stad
zieh aber eiglich ist genau umgekehrt im
Dorf bliebe in der Familie bliebe das
braucht
Mut ja ja genau W du kan die nicht
auchen du bist konfrontiert mit den und
dann fin ich auch wichtig dass man
derwge kommuniziert dass manwi V vorin
seit
erkl vorerkl unbedingt
mit
ja genau nein Blödsinn ich
versu mir ich
glaube
Wien par Stachelschwein im
Winter seit Gesellschaft ist wie eine
Horde von Stachelschwein mit lange
Stachel und S ist kalt im Winter sie D
sich eininander Kuschel und P sich gitig
also geh wieder auseinander
den früh wieder dann geh wieder zammen
den PI sie sich wieder und eigentlich
ist Familie nicht anders oder glückliche
Familie wir versuchen der richtige
Abstand zu den anderen Stachelschwein
finden ich glaube das ist der Punkt wo
man muss auf jeden Fall zwischen n und
Distanz ja und also kann natürlich auch
überlegen was wird heißen die Stachel
abzlecken abzlecken D bist ke
Stachelschwein meh artgerechte
Haltung ist nürich interessant also die
die n die Sehnsucht wich noch
Geborgenheit noch n gichzetig merk man
es funktioniert den nicht und es wird
unwohl warum ist das eigentlich so das
find ich extrem interessantüber noch
denken alsokel Liebe genau liebe deine
Feinde ja W nur die to entspannesucht
sondern auch die mentale Stretch übig
der lauft weniger gefah an wie Naach der
knat den unterem bäumblit ja was sind
eure Tipps für das glung wnachtsf mir
freu e auf euch Kommentar und zum witerl
geht das Gespräch über konstruktiv
stritte und es Bleis und Bart zum Thema
Ritual und euch all jetzt schon freoh
Weihnachtstag